tras el fracaso de llegar a un acuerdo
en el congreso anoche lo que tiene a
perú sin presidente hoy las distintas
bancas regresan para desatascar o
intentar desatascar la votación cuál es
el problema estructural que tiene a la
clase política sumida en una crisis
constante de gobernabilidad señor
murillo
buenos dias alan creo que podríamos
definir el problema estructural de la
situación que vive el país el perú en
torno a cuatro viñetas importantes la
primera diría está vinculada con el
vacío de poder político digamos de
partidos políticos con bases sólidas e
institucionalizadas que hoy si existen
muy precariamente en el perú a raíz de
los hallazgos de la investigación del
caso odebrecht y la bajando estos
hallazgos acabaron en mi opinión con dos
anclas muy importantes que definen el
sistema político pero a lo actual que
fueron las redes que idearon y que
dejaron y que acabaron copando en el
aparato estatal peruano tejidas por el
señor presidente de dos mandatos desde
el año 90 hasta la actualidad como alan
garcía pérez y alberto fujimori fujimori
[Música]
yo diría que estos dos personajes
marcaron de una forma sumamente profunda
el devenir posterior de la política
peruana a nivel de partidos y rostros
desde en los años 90 hasta ahora con él
con los hallazgos del caso odebrecht
estos partidos que digamos las redes que
tejieron estos políticos han caído de
legitimadas a ojos de la población
tenemos además otras tres viñetas de
ella que hay una es las resume esas tres
viñetas en unas diez palabritas señor
murillo es que tenemos muy poco tiempo y
quiero hacer otras dos preguntas
correcto cuatro viñetas vacío del poder
político a nivel de partidos e
institucionalizados
tenemos una descansa institucionalidad
de los poderes del estado una ciudadanía
altamente movilizado y intereses
privados a visión descarnada dos agendas
corporativas oscuras que se pueden
oponer al desarrollo del país en el
parlamento muchas gracias por la
brevedad servido murillo muchas voces
entre ellas las de miles de
manifestantes piden que la nueva mesa
directiva y el nuevo mandatario se elige
entre los 19 congresistas que votaron
contra la vacancia de vizcarra
esto podría disminuir las
y probablemente las podría disminuir
pero para ello tendríamos que llegar a
un consenso en el congreso que no existe
el congreso peruano no ha tenido miedo
de oponerse abiertamente a lo que pide
la población la población no le veía la
cara vizcarra la población pedían
medidas urgentes para sobrevivir a la
paz donde para sobrevivir a la crisis
económica y el parlamento igual lo bajo
sí fue un parlamento que trabaja
directamente según los mandatos de la
población esta postura la elección de un
miembro de la bancada que se opuso a la
votación de la vacancia de vizcarra
sería la solución inmediata pero ya lo
vimos anoche que ni siquiera se pudieron
poner de acuerdo en eso verdad se
continúan con sus negociaciones pequeñas
avanzando sus pequeños intereses para
las elecciones del 2011 mientras que el
país está descabezado en el marco de una
de las peores crisis sanitarias y
económicas de la historia republicana
del perú señor murillo y puede volver el
destituido martín vizcarra a la
presidencia nos quedan unos segunditos
si constitucionalmente podría si es que
el tribunal constitucional así lo
dispone ahora ante una ciudadanía
altamente movilizada ante una ciudadanía
que también ha contemplado atentamente
las severas acusaciones que penden
contra martín vizcarra es mi opinión
personal que muy difícilmente los
manifestantes permitirían el regreso de
martín vizcarra si es que éste fuera
dispuesto por el tribunal constitucional